I am so excited because we have two
legends in our myths here we've got
Kevin Smith and Jason Hughes aka Jay and
Silent Bob my god you are so sweet call
starting with legends you could say
anything to us yes
bolting as you need be okay will do um
Jay and Silent Bob gets a reboot I mean
I'm so excited for this it's been what
how many years in the making 18 well I
mean it like when we finished Jay and
Silent Bob strike back in 2001 there was
never any thought of like oh we will do
this again it felt like one and done and
was for about 18 years and now in 20 19
18 years that a lot of math in this
cancer we finally the one yes I had to
do some this we finally get to do it
again and kind of comes at a time where
you know I've never had a complicated
relationship with Silent Bob like you
sometimes you see Leonard Nimoy gone I
am Spock I am NOT Spock and then I am
Spock I've always liked it you know I've
always kind of embraced it but at a
certain point it felt like people were
just tired like I read online like are
you making another one of them Jay and
Silent Bob type movies and so at that
point I was like maybe we'll put the
toys away and do other things so it's
been a while since I got to play with
two of my favorite toys in the world I'm
not play with myself all the time but in
terms of putting us into a movie and
stuff it's been a while oh wow so we got
to do it and it was it was like going to
the Fountain of Youth to some degree
like I just had the heart attack like a
year and five months ago almost a year
and a half ago at this point we started
shooting the movie one year to the day
of my heart attack one year of tomorrow
attack I was like let's roll cameras
there's a big [ __ ] you to death
so when we went back there was you know
I was I was trying to make the movie pre
heart attack and it was definitely gonna
be funny and stuff but post heart attack
the movie became a feels machine
suddenly like all my priorities were
shifted and stuff and I'm like if I'm
gonna go back in if we're gonna put on
the costumes and do something like that
it has to mean a little more we got to
do something with these characters a
little different and the original joke
of the movie was Jane saw Bob find out
that although it's making a reboot of
that old movie that was based on them
and they go to stop it again so it's
basically the same movies Jay and Silent
Bob strike back but what's different is
on the way and something we kept quiet
all for shooting we just announced with
the trailer on the way Jay finds out
that he's
dad so we run into shannon elizabeth
play justice and strike back and she
tells him that they have a love child so
it becomes this completely different
movie about fatherhood which is
predicated on him because he's the
world's best father i don't even say
that like facetiously or nicely or
something like that I you know I had a
father I was a father I've seen many
fathers in action Jay got a
four-year-old daughter Logan she's in
the movie too he's absolutely amazing as
a dad and after watching him for two
years it just sank in where I'm like
there's the movie like it's it's about
it's about being a parent and what else
are we going to talk about like I'm 48
you know you're how old are you 25 we
can't be sitting around going snootch
each other no you know they're happy but
there had to be a little bit some more
to it men so this one it's very funny
don't get me wrong but it's an oddly
emotional journey to like you're gonna
roll a tear and a Jay and Silent Bob
movie not because you're like it sucks
is actually gonna touch it yeah I mean I
think one of my highlights from
comic-con so far was seeing Ben Affleck
tweet you snooty bujji's and I was like
could be in this movie and then in the
trailer it's revealed he is I mean can
you talk about I mean getting you guys
back together it was just that's such a
moment for faith that was Magic Man that
was thanks to Kevin McCarthy who's a
journalist he's on the news in
Washington yeah nice kid yeah he loves
movies and he loves our movies and every
time he interviewed somebody who's been
in one of our movies because he does
junkets all the time he'll bring up
something from our movies like he's
interviewed map number times and he's
always like when are they making Google
hunting 3 which was a joke we made in
the strike back so he was interviewing
Ben we were in production on reboot
already about two weeks in and he was
interviewing Ben for Netflix to the show
called triple frontier or a movie or
somewhere so Ben was doing his junket
interview and you know Kevin before he
even begins there's questions about the
show just hits him with a general like
hey man reboots happening did they call
you yet and Ben was like no they haven't
and I'm available so and so it was just
kind of hanging there and so Jordan
Jace's wife produce the movie she said
with Liz
jestro both of them were like you should
reach out to Ben man like he said that
thing and I'm like that's just some nice
[ __ ] you say in a junket what was he
supposed to say like I would never work
with them again or something like that
of course he's gonna say oh I wish
they'd call me and they're like no I
felt sincere I was like now nice
I don't know that it's not saying it's
insincere but I didn't hear that as the
call to action or anything and then like
a week went by and I just sat there you
know once again post heart attack things
are different we're even dopey crap like
pride kind of goes away like so like a
year ago or a year and a half ago I
would have let it sit but after a week
and they kept saying just reach out to
him just reach out to him I was like you
know what like it's honestly the worst
that can happen is they'll be like I'll
[ __ ] yourself which I've been you know
feel pretty much feeling like for the
last eight years anyway so I reached out
I wrote this like first it was a tweet
and then Jordan was like don't send a
tweet that's so public I was like I
don't even know if I have one of his
numbers anymore she's like just try one
in your phone and so I Drive on and the
first number I tried as exists you and
he wrote back who's this and I said wait
who are you and he said be a well first
he said your father and then I knew it
was him that's like his sense to you and
then he wrote B yeah he goes who's this
and I said you might stop talking after
I write and I wrote KS and there's a
long beat and then he writes Kevin and
he's like how are you and like instantly
like my heart melts a little bit so I
was like all right I was gonna tweet
this I'm just gonna text it to you and
it was this thing where I got
paraphrased Conan the King Osric scene
where he's hiring Conan he tells Conan
and go find his daughter and stuff and
he's just like there comes a time thief
where you know the the gold loses its
luster and the palace becomes like jail
or something like that and the only
thing an old man is interested in is in
the movies that the love of his daughter
but I broke their is making pretend with
his old friends and so I sent it and
like I was like I'm I've been I've
become incredibly like emo since we
started hanging out so I thought you
might be like keV sounds weird but
instead he wrote back he goes it was so
very Ben he goes I said I did the thing
as king Osric and he writes back it's
very telling that you still think of
yourself as a king
and I was like oh my god it sounds like
him from 96 like this is the sensibility
this is the sense of humor and then we
started talking and I said hey man we're
doing this thing like it would be
amazing if you comply and he's like I'd
love to what can I do and we had shot
everything at this point like there were
no roles left so it was about
manufacturing space for him and so we
had like this little bit that he could
come and did very quickly and would have
been funny and cute but one night I had
a good sleep on and I woke up and I was
like then played Holden who was the
co-creator of Bluntman and chronic in
the mythology of our movies and stuff so
I could pull him in to the third act
like and basically there's a scene that
is the emotional culmination of the
flick that's his scene that didn't exist
prior it was like one throwaway visual
moment but with him going like I'll come
out and play Holden we were able to do
an eight page sequel to chasing amy
right in the middle of chainsaw bob
reboot and he gave us like it's it's
hands-down one of the best if not the
best scene in the movie it's incredibly
emotional it's some of his best
performance definitely some of my best
writing and it's in a Jay and Silent Bob
movie right that to me is the trick that
to me is like after 25 years in this
business I've gotten to a place where I
can take the least likely vehicle and
put stuff in it to deliver to your heart
that you might be surprised by like you
expect me to go for your fine bone
because it's supposed to be a comedy but
at the same time feel for your heart as
well that's all I care about at this
point I want you to feel something and
once you walk out of there feeling like
that not just like I was worth my money
but like I'm glad I'm happy about life
I'm glad those cats are still friends is
the same way that like when I watched
Cobra Kai on YouTube I was elated man as
if family as if these people were family
and stuff like that it's happy to see
these characters back in a place where I
can enjoy their continuing adventures so
I look forward to doing that for
everybody else man this is kind of like
this this is like of all the movies we
made the buspar universe movies this is
like our Avengers end game of that but
we just had way less money but we did
have Thor's that kind of worked I'm just
I mean a flick of the bomb and phantoms
yeah like I'm so funny me to not just
glad that's why I
enough to Kevin McCarthy men like
entertainment journalism was important
yeah you know I'm saying like some
people like how there's a moment that we
would like our movie got better because
he asked a question to somebody that is
unrelated and that's great but more nati
gave my friend back after eight years
piece of my heart was like gone and that
dopey question like changed my life like
my life has reshaped in a way we're like
oh he's back we got the dude back in our
lives who we grew up with we his DNA is
in ours and I don't mean that in a
filthy way but like he's been around
with us forever we grew up together we
came up together and to not have him in
our lives and I'm not even talking about
working with him in movies but just even
personally there was like a big gap big
absence and that absence was filled by
Kevin McCarthy what you do is important
is yeah yeah no I'm sure I'll do
something incredible in here this isn't
your avengers endgame you Jason you just
watched a vendor's endgame for the first
time yes I mean how cool is it though
that you guys are technically a part of
the MCU because in Captain Marvel Stan
Lee was reading the script remoras that
was awesome what was your reaction to
that I saw your your emotional post
Kevin but I was awesome I got anything
would Stan is is amazing and so for to
see him in that movie in his cameo and
then tying it in with Mallrats is where
I first met him I don't know it was
awesome so Jason's got Stan in his movie
as well yeah like we do unfortunately we
didn't get stan was a big part of Jane
ssambap reboot there's a tribute to him
in the movie and stuff but he was meant
to be the one of the main characters in
the third act okay and and I didn't take
his place but I wound up like having to
take a little bit of that role in the
movie myself so he was meant to be with
us and had been for like ever since the
first draft of the script and then we
lost Stan and stuff so he asks every
time he's a cab when you put me in that
movie I want to be in the movie so but
Jason made a movie directing a movie
called madness and the method and Stan
came into the cameo for him and I'm
pretty sure it might be Stan's last Kim
it was right before he passed away but
he came and acted for Jason man it was
in Jason's movie
it was really nice it's not here yeah
when I when I was on set I got a little
teary eyed cuz it was just it was really
nice he was like look I'll come down
hang out for a couple hours but I have
to be home for at 6 o'clock to have wife
at my dinner I mean dinner with my wife
sorry so it was really sweet I thought
but yeah it was all so many came down I
love that now I've been weren't because
you guys are kind of the connective
tissue to a lot of franchises right like
you were in Degrassi right yeah
so does this mean that Degrassi is
technically a part of the MCU yeah
that's what I honestly feel that that
little Mallrats
shoutout in Captain Marvel like not only
firmly ensconced me in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because my name was
on the script but that means anybody if
you're Kevin Smith fan you've seen these
movies you're also in them yeah yeah I
get to bring everyone in with me I felt
pretty good about that I was like Doctor
Strange making circles and bringing
everybody into the now you're also doing
a live reading of clerks 3 can you talk
about you know why you've decided to do
that in Y clerks 3 it has not or maybe
will not get made there's a theater
dinner theater or a dessert theater in
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey Beck where
we come from home our hometowns
Highlands Atlantic is right next to us
when we did the auditions for clerks
back in 1993 I asked Joe bagnolo who
owns that theater as it came in I'm
trying to make this film can I hold
auditions here because they had actors
at the Playhouse when Brian O'Halloran
Marilyn Gigliotti two of our cast
members from clerks were First Avenue
Playhouse players they've been in many
shows there so it was a big part of our
mythology without it we don't get to
clerks and then a couple months ago the
word came back to us that they've fallen
on financially hard times so I said well
let's do a fundraiser for him and the
first thing I thought it was like oh my
god we can read clerks 3 because that's
script for clerks 3 like it'll never
happen now at this point after Jay and
Silent Bob reboot there's there's no
point also the clerks three script I
loved it as one of my favorite things
ever written but it's sad it ends very
sad and post heart attack I'm not
interested in that anymore I'm just
interested in joy so if there was to be
a clerks three it wouldn't
that old script we're about to read so
it's gonna be nice to actually read it
out loud and be like here's what might
have been and I'm not closing the door
on clerks three I just think it'll be
something completely different if I go
back to it it's going to be with the
fervency and enjoy not like it not like
it was going to be a chore to go back to
him the other one but the other clerks
three the one we're gonna read is like
the it's almost like the Macbeth or King
Lear of clerks movies it's about old age
if clerks is about what it's like to be
in your 20s and clerks to is about what
it's like to be in your 30s clerks three
was about what's what it's like facing
the end like less time ahead of you than
in front and nobody when they think of
clerks is going like I want to see like
you know a kind of meditation on my own
demise of course so if I go towards
clerks three again it'd be a completely
different storyline but I'm looking
forward to reading it for all these cats
and and you know nice to be able to go
back home and still help out you know
we're still a big part of where we came
from the comic book store is still in
Red Bank New Jersey and stuff we still
got relatives back there so going back
will be kind of a hoot man it'll be
weird to be in that space again yeah
like I haven't been in the first time to
play us since we did the clerks
auditions in 93 I mean I'm from the East
Coast and it's a big East Coast thing to
just go do like the Kevin Smith tour
like people will like go to the quick
stop and go to the video store the
former video store but yeah it's cool
yeah now you guys are about to do a
really cool thing right after this
you're doing a handprint ceremony is
that correct yeah there's oh that's so
sweet man at the theater and here in
town which is a sister theater to the
Chinese Theatre in Los Angeles they're
letting us do this stuff put our hands I
don't think it's speed to think it's
just hands which is totally cool in the
cement Oh for posterity which is nice
because San Diego is a big town for us
man like we can't we've come here every
year practically since 95
it starts our geek calendar year by
coming here and they've always welcomed
us even where there were other places or
when we've made movies have gone out
into the world and people have been like
this sucks
here we've always been welcomed and
embraced so always sweet to come back
here and it's gonna be amazing to be
here permanently and
a bit of graffiti without getting in
trouble exactly so Jay and Silent Bob
reboot when can we see it comes out in
October there's like to fathom
screenings and then me and him taking on
the road in the reboot Roadshow tour and
then as it opens like we'll say we go to
lexico go we do our show on like a
Wednesday or Thursday then it opens in
Chicago on Friday at theaters and stuff
so it's like a platform release where we
proceed the movie to every market as
opposed to doing it just like big and
wide yeah that's awesome what I look
forward to talking more about it as it
gets closer thank you guys so much
thanks for having ya thank you